Donald Trump is traveling to Mexico
today to meet with president Enrique
Pena Nieto just before delivering this
supposedly major speech laying out his
immigration policy plan once and for all
Donald Trump tweeting about it which is
is actually Trump communicates more via
tweets then through those Harebrained
spokespeople he hires no doubt about
that here's Donald Trump's first tweet
about this I have accepted the
invitation of president Enrique Pena
Nieto of Mexico and look very much
forward to meeting him tomorrow this is
going to be one awkward meeting Trump is
pledging to build a wall and making
Mexico pay for it is part of that plan
hopefully he can explain to the mexican
president exactly how he's going to make
him pay for it Trump has said that
Mexico sends their worse the rapists and
the criminals over to the US maybe that
will be a topic of conversation at this
meeting I hope Donald Trump talks about
the trade deals that he's going to
either destroy or ignore or the taxes
that he's going to place on Mexico that
would of course violate existing trade
deals here is another tweet from Donald
Trump on this issue I love the Mexican
people but Mexico is not our friend
they're killing us at the border and
they're killing us on jobs and trade
fight maybe that to eat will be a topic
of conversation with the Mexican
president and I want to suggest that
this entire thing backfired on the
Mexican president I think it's possible
that the Mexican president invited
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
thinking that Donald Trump wouldn't go
in Hillary Clinton would trump called
his bluff it is not good for Trump it's
sort of obvious if you go Jason and meet
with a president that makes you look
presidential that's a win the problem
though is that now the Mexican president
is legitimizing Donald Trump which I
don't think is really something he wants
to do I think this is a total backfire
for the Mexican president yeah I have no
idea why he's actually entertaining his
audience and having him to his country
the only thing I can maybe think of is
Donald Trump is going to move more of
his
let's say merchandise and uh job
creation to Mexico can you imagine so
publicly Trump is talking about Mexico
bad bad bad we're gonna punish them
we're gonna win we know that at least in
the past Trump was producing I believe
it was his menswear line in Mexico or
something like that imagine if this is
actually a business meeting right the
the public face of it is this is related
to Trump's run for president and he's
actually say listen I want to start
making more of my suits and actually we
want to start using your water supply to
make Trump ice bottled water I don't
actually think that's what's going on
but that would be truly amazing now the
meeting might also be awkward because
the Mexican president has likened Donald
Trump to Adolf Hitler and Mussolini at a
jun 29 press conference with President
Barack Obama as well as the Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau in Ottawa
the Mexican president warned of the
dangers of populism in a globalized
world and defended comments earlier this
year in which he likened Donald Trump to
Adolf Hitler and Benito Mussolini saying
hey Hitler Mussolini we all know the
result it was only a call for reflection
and for recognition so that we bear in
mind what we have achieved and the great
deal still to achieve tonight is this
major major supposedly Trump immigration
speech I have one primary logistical
question that I want answer tonight what
happens to the 11 million undocumented
immigrants already in the United States
Donald Trump has already offered at
minimum three completely different
possibilities it's not clear which one
he believes now he may be will repeat
one of those three as the real and final
piece of his immigration plan tonight or
maybe he will come up with something new
all together I don't know we will be
watching I think the Mexican meeting is
an absolute mistake by the Mexican
president that that seems to have
completely backfired